this episode of fun science is brought
to you by spread the Nets have you ever
been obsessed with a TV show have you
ever completely lost yourself at a good
book
do you also cry like a baby every time
you watch that scene near the end of Toy
Story 3 because even though you know
they're just computer animated toys they
feel like childhood friends you just
can't bear the thought of anything well
if any of that sounded familiar it's
probably because you've found yourself
caring about fictional characters while
we know that these stories aren't real
we still invest our emotions in them as
if they were so why do we do this well
it might be that our brains aren't quite
as good as we'd like at telling the
difference between what's real and
what's fiction take this dot for example
if it just stays there doing nothing as
dots normally do then it's not showing
any signs of life and so we react to it
as we would to any inanimate object
however if I put it inside of a maze and
animate it then it appears as though the
dot has some kind of agency and we
naturally start assigning motivations to
it like hey it's trying to escape the
maze and then we begin to empathize with
it thinking about say how we might feel
if we were inside that place yay it did
it basically so long as something
appears to be an agent
ie we see it displaying a certain level
of autonomy then we react towards it as
if it were alive regardless of whether
or not it actually is now for early man
this likely didn't make any difference
if something showed had agency it was
probably because it was actually alive
however these days it's possible for us
to simulate agency so even when we know
that something isn't really alive
part of our brains still thinks that it
is and this has actually been shown
experimentally when people witnessed
affection directed towards a human a
robot and an inanimate object their
reactions towards the robot and the
human were actually very similar
nice but their reactions towards the
inanimate object not so much I mean you
could eat this now the same idea can be
applied to fictional characters too it
doesn't matter that we know our favorite
TV characters are being portrayed by
actors because subconsciously we believe
those characters are real people what's
more is that sometimes fictional
characters can have an effect on how we
act in the real world it's actually been
shown that when you lose yourself in a
story you can undergo what's called
experience taking when you begin to feel
the thoughts beliefs and emotions of a
character as if they were your own I am
sir Godfrey the great the mightiest
Knight that this here kingdom of shallow
Valhalla you're actually more likely to
lose yourself in a story if it's written
in the first-person perspective or if
you share a strong group identity with
the character in question or sir
I sometimes worry that my tiny armor
makes me look fat well Godfrey the great
has body image issues too well so I
suddenly feel a very strong urge to
protect the kingdom of shallow I'll
holla
now one study actually showed that
participants who went through this
experience taking while reading a story
about someone overcoming obstacles in
order to vote we're actually more likely
to go out and vote in a real election
several days later there are other
studies that have shown similar things
too for example when people lost
themselves in stories where characters
will reveal blatant the narrative to be
of a different sexual orientation or
race to that of the reader the subjects
were found to be less likely stereotyped
against those that they read about by
the way I happen to be homosexual not
that that makes any difference when it
comes to my ability to protect this
beautiful Kingdom I just thought you
might like to know a little bit more
I suddenly feel less biased towards
people who are of a different sexual
orientation to myself thanks progressive
narratives there's also evidence showing
that people who read more stories
overall tend to be more empathetic
in one experiments where people were
tested on their theory of mind which is
your ability to understand the mental
states of others and how they differ
from your own subjects were shown images
of eyes and asked to guess what the
person in the photo was thinking about
and those who got the most correct were
also the people who tended to read the
most fiction so remember to pick the
stories you consume wisely that's not
only could it affect how you see the
world also how you acted it don't get
mad at yourself for getting super
invested in the lives of fictional
characters because as far as your brain
is concerned probably thinks those
people are just as real as anyone else
see you next time thank you so much for
watching everyone if you enjoyed this
video and you'd like to watch some more
science content from this guy for right
now they'll be sure to check out this
video that I made for planned
international Canada and spread the net
which is about the science behind the
malaria disease and what you can do
right now to help prevent people from
getting it and save lives so do please
give that a watch and I also want to say
a big thank you to everyone who is
supporting fun science on patreon I'm
incredibly thankful it's very surprising
to me and it means a lot and for anyone
else you might be considering helping us
to make fun science do head on over to
patreon comm or slash fun science for
more information on that thanks a lot
guys